they are Ukraine's Defenders fathers
mothers friends and neighbors
we are happy about the liberation of
territories wow this is great we are
moving forward but we don't always
understand Thanks To whom it happens
Ukraine has not confirmed with the world
how many soldiers it has lost since
Russia breached its borders in February
loss is measured here in much more
intimate terms empty beds and missing
Smiles
until the end he stood and defended not
only our country City and Europe but
also our family
this day is even more important to me
now I think it's obvious because this
day has cost me the highest possible
price I've ever paid Defenders day was
first celebrated in 2015.
crane has fought separatists backed by
Russia for years in the East now every
region Bears Battle Scars daily Russian
forces shell cities and towns across
Ukraine we don't set ourselves the task
of destroying Ukraine Vladimir Putin
says no of course not many ukrainians
consider the Russian president a war
criminal who's taken all they have
we will surely spend winter here because
we have nowhere else to go nowhere to
stay this child six months old has only
known life underground the large
basement below the factory where Olaf
shevchenko's husband works lacks the
comfort of a home but offers something
priceless
protection
Crystal gomancing Global News London